vous vous êtes conseiller sportif c'est
que vous faites quoi en fait au sein du
PSG vous êtes au sein du PSG je
conseille des joueuses au sein du Paris
Saint-Germain d'accord et d'autres clubs
en France il y a l'étranger d'accord
vous êtes pas chaud vous êtes vous avez
une société exactement c'est ça et donc
vous conseiller des joueurs sur quoi sur
les sur les transferts sur sur ce
qu'elles vont faire sur comment d'abord
les performances sportives d'accord
la vie au quotidien d'accord puis je
prends juste la partie négociation
sportive et pour paraphrer j'ai une
structure du côté de la Belgique avec
qui je collabore et c'est eux qui
paravent les contrats d'accord donc vous
n'êtes pas vraiment c'est pas agent mais
c'est je ne suis pas vieux je ne suis
pas le voilà vous êtes juste voilà vous
êtes à l'intermédiaire vous occupez des
voilà des des sportifs de haut niveau
je conseille les footballeuses féminines
d'accord d'accord alors vous êtes un
proche d'Aminata Diallo exactement c'est
quoi c'est au départ c'était quoi
c'était une relation de travail et après
c'est devenu une amie parce que non de
base c'est une geste de Paris
Saint-Germain d'accord et puis c'est une
copine de ma concubine
et dans le cadre de la ville exactement
voilà donc c'est ce qu'on disait la
dernière fois et aujourd'hui vous êtes
au cœur de cette affaire on va rappeler
toute cette affaire Gilles avant d'en
parler avec César et son avocat pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent ce
vendredi 23 septembre qu'est ce qui se
passe pour résumer l'année dernière une
joueuse du PSG Keira Amraoui victime
d'une agression à coups de barre de fer
dans sa voiture on soupçonne
immédiatement sa coéquipière à Minata
qui est en garde à vue et puis qui sort
libre de garde à vue et on s'oriente
vers une affaire de d'adultère ou
plusieurs affaires de vie privée et puis
finalement coup de théâtre Aminata
Diallo est mise en examen placé en
détention puis libérée donc elle est
soupçonnée d'avoir commandité
l'agression de sa coéquipière et vous
êtes au cœur du débat parce que il y a
énormément d'écoute téléphonique de
communication avec Aminata Diallo où on
vous on vous lit on lit vos déclarations
et vous semblez en fait préparer cette
association avec Aminata Diallo en vue
peut-être d'agresser madame Amraoui
alors voilà juste on va mais vous êtes
présumé innocents
à ce moment-là juste dans le déroulé qui
a été évoqué et dans le vôtre
pardonnez-moi mais il manque quelque
chose c'est que il a été entendu par la
police il est sorti libre et qu'il ait
été considéré comme un témoin libre pour
noter les spectateurs il y a le témoin
libre le statut le plus bas vous et moi
on pourrait être entendu dans cette
affaire après il y a le témoin assisté
après il y a le mise en examen il y a le
garder à vue aujourd'hui César il faut
bien le redire pour que les gens le
comprennent bien il est témoin libre il
n'a jamais été mis en examen et jamais
gardé à vue voilà il y a juste une voilà
un petit complément dans la chronologie
c'est important
libre absolument il y a pas de charge
retenu contre vous mais il y a quand
même un faisceau de d'écoute
téléphonique monsieur alors qu'est-ce
qu'elle disait ses écoutes alors ces
écoutes téléphoniques à 33 conversations
avec Aminata Diallo et notamment il y a
une écoute téléphonique où vous menacez
de révéler un scandale sexuel au sein du
Paris Saint-Germain si jamais et là si
jamais trois petits points si jamais
Aminata Diallo n'est pas revalorisé si
jamais elle n'aurait signe pas etc comme
si vous mettiez la pression sur le club
voilà est-ce que ça est-ce que ça vous
répondre il va vous répondre
ainsi que sa famille
et également pour mademoiselle Aminata
Diallo ainsi que sa famille qu'on soit
bien clair Aminata c'est une proche
je ne veux pas le nier
je le dis publiquement devant tous les
téléspectateurs devant
un poil plus fort c'est pas pour moi
c'est pour Daniel Moreau
merci ça marche merci ensuite
mademoiselle
Aminata Diallo a été mis en cause
c'est le début de la faire par
Mademoiselle
Amaoui
et moi dans la foulée
donc je réponds à une convocation de
le commandant penaud de la BRB de 78
j'y vais en toute tranquillité parce que
encore une fois je n'ai strictement rien
à voir ni de près ni de loin dans cette
histoire
je peux juste ajouter une chose c'est
que par rapport à ce que vous dites à
l'instant c'est que à aucun moment
le fait de placer sous écoute quelqu'un
et le fait de dévoiler qu'il a eu des
propos durs c'est une preuve de quoi que
ce soit je suis je suis certain que si
on met chacun d'entre vous sous écoute
vous avez parfois des propos durs sur
vos collègues ah oui je comprends voilà
les révélations sexuelles le scandale
sexuel dont vous vous parliez c'est ça
correspond à quoi
j'ai une concubine
qui joue au Paris Saint-Germain
j'entends des rumeurs
comme quoi
j'entends des rumeurs mettez-vous à ma
place donc sur quoi sur une main
baladeuse sur une jeune joueuse mineure
à l'époque d'accord donc de la part d'un
entraîneur du PSG qui n'est plus là
j'ai un rendez-vous dans le cadre des
négociations de la prolongation du
contrat de Marie-Antoinette auto la star
du PSG la star du Paris Saint-Germain et
j'ai une pensée pour elle elle a aussi
une famille elle a été mis en cause
aussi dans cette histoire
donc j'ai monsieur
Ulrich Ramé directeur sportif à l'époque
avec Grégory Durand
responsable juridique du club à aucun
moment je l'ai je l'ai eu des propos
menaçants j'ai juste relaté des faits
que nous avons entendu qui tournait
autour du vestiaire mais c'est pas des
menaces voilà j'ai juste relaté on
présence de Monsieur Grégory Durand
alors ailleurs qui fait un travail
énorme
parce que ce qui se passe c'est donc que
4 novembre ami nata Diallo ramène Kirin
Amraoui mercredi en voiture les deux
femmes sont arrêtées par deux hommes
cagoulés et Kira Amraoui est frappé à
coup de barre de fer
César vous n'avez rien à voir dans cette
affaire mais Cyril comment vous la
prenez vous la prenez moi j'ai appris le
lendemain d'accord il faut savoir que
moi la veille toute la journée j'étais à
mon domicile dans 78 ensuite
je me suis rendu dans mon restaurant que
je détiens de du côté de la commune de
Créteil
je change mon texto avec ma concubine
qui me demande de venir la chercher dans
cette même soirée avec toutes les
joueuses du côté de bois de Boulogne
d'accord donc je lui réponds ok pas de
souci je vais passer
je finis au restaurant je veux voir le
bijoutier à côté qui a de mes associés
dans lequel dans le domaine minier où je
travaille aussi en Angola nous avons une
structure une société on peut le
vérifier
je prends la route
de Créteil dans le 94 jusqu'au bois de
Boulogne je me gare devant alors c'est
dans une sorte d'île vous voyez on prend
un bateau pour
arriver pour récupérer les véhicules je
vois le groupe des filles sortir de loin
sur le côté droit moi j'étais un peu
plus loin sur côté gauche en sortant
donc
Marion toilette Catteau elle sort
maniaba folkien
sort en même temps je les vois elles
peuvent témoigner en échange ça va les
filles tout va bien ça s'est bien passé
ok merci au revoir ma concubine vient à
ce moment là on prend notre véhicule on
prend la direction du périph
ensuite le boulevard Charles de Gaulle
du côté de Neuilly
la A14 je sors chez moi à la sortie de
chez moi j'ai dormi je n'ai strictement
encore une fois et ça rien à voir alors
cette histoire rien à voir est-ce que
c'était quoi vos rapports
je la connais pas d'accord je ne la
connais point comment vous expliquer que
votre nom ressort César sur des simples
critiques sportifs d'accord une fois
c'est des gens malveillants qui vous ont
mis dans la sauce mais vous savez Cyril
aujourd'hui
je suis quand même à la tête de deux
joueuses nommées au Ballon d'Or c'est ça
qui est Mario toilette Katoto et
kadiatoudiani deux fois élu meilleur
joueur du championnat par
la jalousie
il y a des agents il y a aussi des
personnes qui ne sont plus là à ce stade
au sein du Paris Saint-Germain batillons
un petit peu on va dire les boules
d'accord donc vous pensez que c'est pour
ça qu'on vous a mis dans la sauce moi je
ne pense rien à moi d'accord est-ce que
je me réserve juste le droit de me
défendre quand vous avez appris
l'agression de terrain j'étais choqué
comme tout le monde 3 ou 3 mecs qui
tombent sur sur une femme déjà
c'est c'est un acte aux gens qui disent
que moi je me fais voilà je vous dis
tout ce qui sort comme ça au moins on
met tout à plat aujourd'hui il y a des
gens qui disent que vous aviez conseillé
ami nata Diallo je vois sur les quelques
articles d'écarter la concurrence par
tous les moyens qu'est-ce que vous leur
dites moi je n'ai conseillé personne moi
j'ai conseillé à Minata de faire des
bonnes prestations sur un terrain
sur un point de vue amical d'accord je
lis par ci par là que Madame
faisait Mbappé pareil
commenter la star mondiale de football
que je connais pas personnellement que
j'ai croisé lors d'une soirée Wilfried
Mbappe figurez-vous que je connais papa
je connais très bien puisque moi quand
je suis arrivé en France en 89
je suis arrivé à Bondy
ça a été mon premier entraîneur
avec nous au gymnase Jean Zay
aujourd'hui je ne la côtoie plus je ne
la vois pas je n'ai pas son numéro ça
s'appelle pas du tout mais
alors c'est ça juste d'où vous n'avez
rien conseillé mais après l'agression
vous avez communiqué avec Camille nata
Diallo vous cessez d'utiliser la ligne
mobile traditionnelle vous optez pour
des messageries cryptées pourquoi mais
attendez mais tout le monde aujourd'hui
je ne suis pas là pour défendre un
million 4 dialogue encore une fois
mettez-vous à la place de sa famille
elle est présumée innocente elle a une
mère il y a des personnes âgées on
accuse votre enfant alors je sais pas ce
que ça va donner demain
il y a pas d'amitié à deux vitesses moi
c'est mon ami
je vais la soutenir je vais pas aller
dans une folie avec elle mais si demain
ça va dans le sens j'assumerai pour vous
donc
vous n'avez parce que il y a aussi il y
avait il y a aucune charge qui me pèse
aujourd'hui mais il y aura pas de charge
je n'ai rien à voir aujourd'hui au delà
de l'agression il y en a qui vous accuse
d'avoir ensuite
tout fait pour évincer keramrawick ce
que vous dites à ces gens c'est c'est
quoi c'est encore des des qu'on
dira-t-on c'est encore des gens qui
voulaient très clair là-dessus
alors nous sommes dans le milieu du
football féminin
on se connaît je conseille des jeux les
jeux parlent entre elles
avant qu'elle arrive a eu des rumeurs
moi j'ai donné mon point de vue
à Monsieur
Ulrich il peut venir ici demain sur le
plateau je peux confronter avec lui
l'indice ça m'arrange
après ton anniversaire très bien joyeux
anniversaire merci merci et donc à
l'époque dirigeant du PSG il faut
préciser directeur voilà j'ai été clair
on a un jeune groupe elle se connaissent
un an auparavant elles ont été
championnes de France pour la première
fois au sein du Paris Saint-Germain
c'est énorme je lui dis monsieur
en tant que spécialiste dans le football
féminin
du groupe il faut rester dans
l'équilibre faut pas ramener des
éléments
nuisibles donc là vous essayez de
valoriser vos joueuses quand même non
pas du tout ce que vous êtes entre
j'ai deux joueuses nommé au Ballon d'Or
par deux fois élu meilleur joueuse de
championnat mais en quoi on va en vie et
Mademoiselle amarui je n'ai pas de haine
envers
il y a des enregistrements qui disent
qui ont fait voilà énormément parler
quand vous dites les il faut vous
fustiger les racailles de babtou qu'il
faut découper au sein du club
comment vous expliquer ça c'était voilà
Cyril moi je suis pas raciste
je viens de banlieue d'accord moi pour
moi il y a pas de banlieue c'est la
France
excusez-moi madame je sais que ça peut
choquer mais moi dans le milieu on
m'appelle bah ça va renoi tu vas bien
voilà découper les racailles de Bach
tout c'est violent quand même mais non
mais nous moi quand on traite de
racaille
ok c'est vous voulez mais en fait encore
une fois c'est les conversations privées
dans des conversations privées on a tous
des moments dans lequel on dit des
choses dans lequel on exagère ce qu'on
pense on a droit de se charrier il parle
avec quelqu'un qui est une amie il
essaie de lui exprimer ça et d'ailleurs
je je j'invite ceux qui ont dévoilé ces
écoutes à dévoiler tout le reste des
écoutes parce que parfois c'est
quelqu'un de très gentil oui mais enfin
il dit par exemple sur Keira oui l'autre
[ __ ] elle sera titulaire c'est un truc
de malade et réveillez-vous les filles
je sais pas qu'est-ce que moi j'ai pas
eu les PV parce qu'encore une fois je me
permets de reconstruire en fait comme il
n'est pas une mise en examen on n'a pas
accès au PV donc en fait on ne sait
absolument pas si ce qui est dit est
vrai et regardez par exemple j'ai vu
dans l'article du Parisien qu'on le
traite de complice présumé c'est pas une
qualification juridique le titre du
Parisien c'est main basse sur le PSG
avec tout le respect que j'ai pour César
qui n'est d'ailleurs ni mystérieux ni
intermédiaire c'est quelqu'un qui est
officiel il y a pas de problème vous
pensez vraiment que César va faire main
basse sur le PSG j'ai des très bonnes
relations avec le Paris Saint-Germain je
continue à collaborer avec eux c'est ça
vous en voulez même remercier le Qatar
on doit même remercier Monsieur
aujourd'hui on a la chance d'avoir Messi
Mbappé Neymar
on le remercie également pour mes places
qui sont pas plaisir à aller voir le
Paris Saint-Germain jouer aujourd'hui
quand le Parisien parle de pactes scellé
entre vous et
la joueuse qui est terminée
aujourd'hui elle a décidé d'arrêter sa
carrière moi je l'avais conseillé de
continuer elle a plus rien
elle a fait trois ou quatre jours ou 5
jours de prison
si elle est fragile dans sa tête elle
s'accroche et demande découvre la vérité
que c'est pas il en fait comment alors
justement c'est
toutes les informations ces informations
ont été dévoilées notamment par
l'enquête du Parisien on a eu Ronan qui
est venu ici
cette enquête vous vous l'avez lu
qu'est-ce que vous dites de cette
enquête mais j'en ai excusez-moi je veux
pas être vulgaire j'en ai strictement
rien à [ __ ] me concernant moi ma
personne parce que je n'ai rien à voir
c'est embêtant vis-à-vis des gens qui
vous côtoient de votre famille etc mais
c'est pour ça que je suis ici sur mon
plateau voilà il y a ma concubine qui
subit des menaces qui se fait insulter
dans les réseaux j'ai Marie-Antoinette
Toto qui s'est fait les croiser
j'ai emmené j'ai pris la route à 6h du
matin et j'ai emmené du côté de
Hauteville pas loin d'Annecy pour des
soins spécifiques d'accord je suis
reparti à midi du côté jusqu'à du côté
de Sedan pour voir le match de l'équipe
de France parce que ma concubine est
joué et je suis rentré chez moi à 3
heures du matin
je suis un agent mystérieux ou non juste
un conseiller qui fait son travail
forcément forcément il y a des
partenaires qui auraient pu se
positionner et qui sont en train de se
positionner sur Marion toilette Katoto
et qu'elle étudiani certains sont en
train de reculer et je peux aussi
comprendre de l'autre côté du côté de
Mademoiselle Amraoui donc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tout ce qui a été dit vous
fait énormément de mal professionnels et
mais forcément j'ai
la sœur d'une de mes joueuses
qui est très inquiète et qui a même
conseillé à sa à sa petite sœur
d'arrêter avec de collaborer avec moi
travailler vous avez du taf
j'ai énormément pas c'est ça mais les
gens ils vous disent quoi parce que
c'est vrai que voilà on se dit est-ce
que il se méfie est-ce qu'ils sont ils
voilà qui vous avez dit voilà il y avait
deux joueuses là dont vous occupez on
vous sentez que ça ça coince un peu
c'est donc il faut il faut mettre tout
ça voilà j'ai aussi des jeux ce qu'ils
veulent quand même malgré ça
venir dans ma structure j'ai eu des
messages de maman qui m'ont apporté leur
soutien et de du père en l'occurrence
d'une joyeuse à moi qui m'a dit César
écoute
on lit partout mais tant que tu n'es pas
condamné non on te fera confiance moi ce
qui m'importe c'est de défendre les
intérêts de mes joueuses d'accord voilà
j'ai pas vocation à à être agent et être
dans ce milieu pendant 15-20 ans non je
suis juste conseillé par une advertance
au départ parce que j'ai commencé à
conseiller ma concubine et ensuite les
autres filles sont les échanges bah ils
m'ont fait confiance il y a Minata c'est
du conseil amical Aminata Aminata vous
avez le sentiment
vraiment qu'elle est innocente
je suis persuadé c'est votre ami vous en
êtes persuadé je persuadéro doute pour
vous pour moi 02 donc pour vous est-ce
que vous avez sans nous les dit en bien
entendu est-ce que vous avez des
présomptions sur sur d'autres personnes
qui auraient pu commenter cette personne
présumée innocente avec ou voilà alors
les inspecteurs faut qu'il fasse leur
travail jusqu'au bout justement ces
quatre personnes Gilles Verdez est-ce
que vous pouvez expliquer à nos
spectateurs parce que c'est vrai que
cette affaire voilà elle intéresse
énormément c'est vrai que c'est au-delà
d'une affaire de football
qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce moment pour
le moment donc Aminata Diallo est mise
en examen mais il reste à déterminer qui
serait l'intermédiaire et qui serait le
commanditaire de cette affaire il y a
d'autres personnes mises en examen qui
ont donné les coûts mais
l'intermédiaire éventuellement le
commanditaire sont encore mystérieux et
c'est vrai que son avocat nous le disait
il n'y a pas d'éléments matériels qui
cherchent pour le moment Aminata Diallo
donc l'affaire est encore en cours les
policiers tentent de remonter pour
savoir qui aurait pu commanditer cette
agression de Madame Amraoui est-ce que
ça dépasse réaminata Diallo est-ce qu'il
y a une autre piste d'autres pistes de
vie privée c'est ce que Maître bathique
l'avocat d'Aminata Diallo tente de
savoir également voilà je vous réponds
juste quand même par rapport à ça parce
que vous dites qui pourrait être
l'intermédiaire et je trouve que le jeu
sur les mots est un peu curieux j'en
profite pour dire que la police et le
Parisien aussi parce que on est sur le
plateau j'en profite pour vous annoncer
que on a déposé plainte avec César
contre les journaux qui ont construit
cette histoire donc une plainte a été
déposée pour diffamation à l'encontre du
journal Le Point et le Parisien et
également à référer pour que soit
respecté sa vie privée parce que il est
obligé de venir ce soir et c'est on est
ravi d'être là pour donner sa vérité
c'est mon anniversaire mais mais il
voulait pas au départ c'est quelqu'un
qui est un professionnel je suis joyeux
anniversaire
pro qui passe son temps je connais bien
à regarder des matchs de télé voilà pour
analyser les matchs les positionnements
qui passent son temps avec ses joueuses
qui voulaient pas être mis là-dedans on
est obligé de le faire et donc on va se
défendre jusqu'au bout pour démontrer
son innocence et qu'on arrête comme le
dit très bien Siri de le mettre dans la
sauce voilà alors justement c'est ça
aujourd'hui vous
vous le redite à noter les spectateurs
qui nous rejoignent à 21h11 vous n'avez
rien à voir dans cette affaire où vous y
Amélie par quel billet c'est des gens
qui ont témoigné qui ont fait des
témoignages des faux témoignages contre
vous qui ont monté la sauce contre vous
c'est les écouteurs j'ai l'impression
que c'est pas la même personne et à
chaque fois ça me fait ça j'ai juste
cette question là on a lu quand même
beaucoup de phrases on en a vu deux là
est-ce que ça vous reconnaissez que
c'est vous cette cellule vraie
conversation
sans une pointe arrogance sans une
pointe arrogance je vous le dis vraiment
en toute tranquillité
strictement rien à voir je vous le dis
ici sur le plateau
devant toute la France entière on verra
la finalité
moi ce qui m'apporte c'est la finalité
pour moi
pour
Aminata Diallo et surtout surtout pour
la victime qui ira Mori aussi parce que
voilà faut que la vérité sorte c'est
tout mais ce qui trouble quand même
au fil des écoutes on sent une pression
que vous mettez c'est vrai que là on
vous entend parfaitement avec votre
avocat c'est très construit mais on sent
quand même qu'il y a une volonté entre
guillemets je vais utiliser un mot fort
de régenté de mettre sous coupe réglé le
club du PSG section féminine c'est ce
qui ressort des écoutes monsieur c'est
pour ça que c'est honnête de vous le
dire le club le club le club en soi le
club en soi pour moi c'est un grand club
il y a des gens qui font un travail
énorme
je peux vous citer rue Durand je peux
vous citer
Angelo Castaldi le nouveau directeur
sportif
et non pas directeur financier
les nouveaux que les anciens et le
nouveau pression sur les anciens que
vous mettez au fil des écoutes pour qui
dégage mais on lui pose on lui pose des
questions on lui demande son avis parce
qu'il est reconnu dans ce milieu là il
va il va dire j'ai pas le droit de
parler simplement au téléphone
aujourd'hui on a le meilleur entraîneur
au Paris Saint-Germain Gérard prêcheur
qui a d'ailleurs gagné avec l'Olympique
Lyonnais c'est une grande région
d'accord et
c'est vrai alors non juste pour noter
les spectateurs à 21h13
voilà il s'occupe voilà vous êtes
l'agent officieux de plusieurs joueuses
du PSG même pas conseiller
monsieur vous êtes un proche d'amis nata
Diallo vous auriez de quoi vous êtes
accusé et aujourd'hui certains
soupçonnent d'avoir pris part à
l'agression d'Aminata Diallo il n'a été
entendu que comme témoin par la justice
et n'est pas poursuivi à l'heure
actuelle il faut vraiment le rappeler
parce que voilà agression de karamaüs
excusez-moi voilà il aurait et on dit
que vous auriez passé un pacte avec
Aminata dans un seul but tout faire pour
émincer Kera Hamra oui du PSG voilà ce
qui est aujourd'hui est reproché à
césarienne on le voit je le redis il a
été entendu que comme témoin par la
justice aujourd'hui il n'est pas du tout
poursuivi voilà quelques manières que ce
soit césarienne il faut le redire voilà
si vous vous me confirmez est-ce que
vous nous avez confirmé il y a un
instant oui donc non seulement il est
pas il a été on l'a laissé sortir libre
pas en garde à vue pas en examen et
j'ajoute maintenant parce que c'est le
moment de contre-attaquer toutes les
personnes qui diront que il est à
l'origine d'un complot etc qui sont
quelques sortes complotistes seront
poursuivis en diffamation voilà parce
qu'à un moment faut arrêter de se faire
marcher dessus aussi oui Valérie pour
revenir sur les points justement de
l'article que vous attaquez pardon pour
revenir sur les points de l'article que
vous attaquez
l'explication qu'il donne eux de la mise
sur écoute de votre client de Monsieur
c'est que en fait il y avait une
communication téléphonique qui avait été
détectée entre la ligne que vous
utilisiez et un certain corbeau qui
aurait menacé des joueuses et donc c'est
ça qui leur met la puce à l'oreille en
disant tiens étonnant que ce corbeau
soit en lien avec Monsieur est-ce que
sur ce point de cet article vous
pourriez avoir une je pense là je sais
absolument pas qui est ce corbeau il se
trouve que effectivement César il a des
conversations avec plein de gens dans le
milieu du foot on n'a pas l'identité
enfin c'est le propre problème d'un
corbeau je ne sais pas qui c'est et
encore une fois je n'ai pas accès au
dossier il n'est pas mis en examen je ne
sais pas je dois être là je dois vous
dire la vérité on ne sait pas donc en
fait tout ça nous est tombé dessus
dimanche soir d'occasion d'une émission
on dit il semblerait que peut-être
monsieur César m je vous dis encore il
est pas sulfureux il est là il est pas
intermédiaire il est conseillé donc
voilà
mais je sais pas qui est le corbeau ni
le pigeon ou quoi que ce soit
apparemment il est percé sur un arbre
il tient dans son bec un fromage
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à
toutes nos questions et je le rappelle
voilà c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut
retenir aujourd'hui pour le moment
vraiment césarienne n'aille temps
entendu que pas témoin libre à la
justice donc aujourd'hui rien n'est
retenu contre lui il est parfaitement
libre voilà donc mettre
entendu elle va être entendu ça je sais
pas mais en tout cas si vous voulez
peut-être parce que vous êtes dans une
émission qui est vraiment très écoutée
c'est la différence entre le traitement
médiatique et le traitement judiciaire
très souvent en ce moment on confond le
traitement médiatique et le traitement
judiciaire et peut-être que avec cette
affaire on va montrer qu'on peut pas
éreinter la réputation d'un homme et de
ses proches de cette façon là César
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans quel état
l'esprit
serein serein vous avez envie de tout ça
se règle pour passer
il y a beaucoup de dégâts j'ai des jeux
j'ai ma concubine j'ai mariantoinette
qui qui ont une famille voilà ils ont
des neveux nièces parents
voilà faut et surtout que la vérité
sorte voilà comme ça aussi mademoiselle
Larabie pour passer à autre chose